هل ما تزال قوات الاحتلال
في المنطقه التي قامت
بتفجير منزل الشهيد
القواسمي ال انسحبت قوات الاحتلال نشوان
قبل حوالي ساعه من الان بعد عمليه عسكريه
موسعه استمرت لحوالي سبع الى ثمان ساعات
خلالها قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت حي دائره
السير في المدينه واغلقت كافه الطرق
المؤديه الى منزل الشهيد عبد القادر
القواسم الذي نقف الان على انقاضه ويظهر
في هذه الصوره هذا الدمار الكبير الذي
خلفه الاحتلال بعد هدم هذا المنزل كما
قامت بالتزامن مع عمليه الهدم التي كانت
تتم هذه الليله في هذه المنطقه كان هناك
تفجير ايضا لمنزل الشهيد نصر الله القواسم
الذي فجر على مرحلتين المرحله الاولى قوات
الاحتلال فجرت المنزل ولم تكتفي بهذا
التفجير بعد حوالي ساعه من التفجير جير
الاول قامت قوات الاحتلال بتفجير المنزل
لمره ثانيه الامر الذي ادى الى انهياره
بشكل كامل بمعنى ان هذه العمليه التي جرت
في مدينه الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه هذه
الليله اسفرت عن هدم منزلين منزل الشهيد
عبد القادر القواسمي ونصر الله القواسمي
مع الاشاره الى ان هنالك منزل ثالث مخترم
بالهدم ايضا في الخليل للشهيد حسن قفيشه
الذي نفذ مع الشهيد عبد القادر القواسمي
ونصر الله القواسمي عمليه عند عن حاجز
النفق جنوبي القدس في السادس عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي اسفرت عن مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي واصابه سبعه اخرين بعد هذه
العمليه قوات الاحتلال اخطرت هذه المنازل
بالهدم ومنذ اسبوعين قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
هذه المنطقه بشكل مستمر وبشكل متواصل
وتقوم باخذ القياسات والتقاط الصور وتحذير
الاهالي والسكان الذين قامت قوات الاحتلال
بافراغ من بيوتهم ومن مساكنهم هذه الليله
كافه المنازل المحيطه قوات الاحتلال اجبرت
ساكنيها على الخروج منها كما امرت ايضا
اصحاب المركبات التي كانت تصطف على المدخل
المؤدي الى هذا الحي بازالتها وشرعت
بالفعل بهذه العمليه التي استمرت كما
ذكرنا لحوالي سبع ساعات هذه او او ما جرى
في الخليل يندرج في اطار وفي سياق السياسه
التي تتبعها قوات الاحتلال مؤخرا في الضفه
الغربيه بالهدم الذي جرى هذه الليله في
الخليل بلغ عدد حالات الهدم منذ السابع من
اكتوبر حتى تاريخ هذا اليوم 23 حاله هدم
لمنازل فلسطينيين ابنائهم شاركوا في
عمليات ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
هذا ينظر اليه في اطار سياسه العقاب
الجماعي التي تتبعها قوات الاحتلال بحق
الفلسطينيين حيث تهدم منازلهم